- [Reporter] Explosions
and fires in Crimea
have destroyed military
equipment, frightened beach goers,
and prompted thousands of
residents to evacuate to Russia.
After more than eight years
under Moscow's control,
scenes of war have returned to Crimea.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Reporter] For several recent incidents,
Ukraine hasn't claimed responsibility,
but Russia's operations have
been seriously disrupted
as Ukraine increasingly
focuses on striking facilities
and supplies behind Russian lines.
- Actually, what they're doing
is part of a broader strategy
which is to try to squeeze the Russians
out of the south of the country.
- [Reporter] So as the
war enters a new phase
and President Zelensky vows
to take back the territory
at the heart of Russia's operations,
here's why Crimea has emerged
as an important battleground.
Russia's military seized Crimea,
which is internationally
recognized as Ukrainian territory,
in 2014.
Since then, Moscow has
built military bases
and weapons stores on the peninsula.
(speaking foreign language)
- [Reporter] When Russia invaded
Ukraine in late February,
those hubs became important locations
from where Moscow could deploy
forces and top up supplies.
- In the early days of
the war, Crimea was used
as a jump off point for Russia's military.
- [Reporter] Russia's initial strategy
was a multi-directional invasion
with the goal of capture and
keep, but after that failed,
fighting shifted to Eastern
and Southern Ukraine.
- Since then, it's Crimea
that's been kind of a rear base
for Russian armed forces who are occupying
the south of Ukraine.
Ukraine is now attempting
to push those forces out.
(explosion booming)
- [Reporter] Since taking control of parts
of Eastern Ukraine in July,
Russia's forces have appeared to slow down
and Ukraine has repeatedly
hit occupied areas
with targeted strikes
on key infrastructure
that was being used by the invaders.
- Ukraine, it thinks it
can't take the Russians on
in a tank battle.
So they're being clever about it.
Their aim is to degrade the Russians.
The Ukrainian official said to me,
it's like 1,000 stings from a bee
in order to disable Russian capabilities,
their ability to wage
war and demoralize them
and force them to withdraw.
- [Reporter] Crimea is
now key to that strategy.
A blast at a Russian airbase on August 9th
destroyed several war planes,
according to Western
intelligence officials.
And as seen in these satellite images
that contradicted Moscow's claim
that no war planes were lost.
Russia blamed an ammunition explosion,
and Ukraine didn't take
responsibility for the damage.
But the blast had consequences.
Russia relocated some planes
and aircraft to its mainland,
according to Ukrainian
military intelligence.
A week after the airbase was hit,
explosions at an ammunition
depot damaged rail tracks
and power lines,
complicating Russia's efforts
to transport ammunition
and other supplies.
Ukrainian officials said the
attack was indeed Ukrainian,
and Russian officials blamed saboteurs
in their first official acknowledgement
of a major attack on the peninsula.
Still, that doesn't
necessarily mean Ukraine
is about to retake Crimea.
- Certainly Crimea eventually is a target,
but the Ukrainians are going
about it very methodically,
piece by piece.
- [Reporter] Russian diplomats
didn't respond to a request
for comment about the effects
of what's happening in Crimea
on Moscow's campaign.
But as a new phase starts in the conflict,
the peninsula is at the
center of Ukraine's efforts
to show that it can damage Russia's army
where it didn't expect it.